well it's not just gas prices sending
consumers into shock russia and ukraine
supply nearly a third of the world's
wheat and since the invasion exports
have come to a standstill meaning
shoppers could also see a spike in
prices for things like cereal and bread
ukraine is the bread basket of europe
right so there is a lot of concern that
this is going to make a inflationary
problem even worse
well there are also meat concerns since
some farmers rely on wheat to feed
livestock
well valley restaurants and bakeries are
already noticing products costing more
joe muller joining us live now outside
west side bagel shop with how business
owners are navigating and navigating the
added expense joe
christian businesses are noticing a
number of products costing more
especially wheat we spoke to the owner
here at bagel cafe this is near buffalo
and summerlin parkway we spoke to the
owner he tells us he's trying to
navigate these costs while keeping
prices down
50 pound bag we used to get it
16 17 now it's up to 21
bagel cafe is a restaurant deli and
bakery they go through a lot of flour to
make all of these items owner savas
andrews says while his product is from
the u.s he knows more countries are
going to be wanting that same product
now because less is being produced in
europe every day mma managers were
scrambling around just to check you know
pricing it's like a fine line
how much do you charge before they stop
coming in especially now with the fuel
prices people are going to be watching
their budgets the american bakers
association says wheat prices are up 11
percent since january and are expected
to go up even more with gas on the rise
andrews worries about all the extra
costs
back out here live we also went to a
coffee shop downtown that bakes their
own pastries for the shop there and they
say they're trying to navigate these
costs as well what they're doing is
simply making more throughout the day so
they have left less left over to toss
out at the end of the day less waste so
they have more product throughout the
entire week so business is really trying
to figure this all out reporting live
near summerlin jim muller live vocal now